is just around the corner and you want
to make sure kids start with clear
vision joining us to talk about eye
exams for kids and cool glasses is dr
jennifer burke she is from the vision
council and optometrist at ideology
vision care thank you dr burke for being
here thank you so much for having me
here today let's talk about eye exams
that is important to do before the
school year starts because it can be so
difficult if a child is not able to see
what's on the board at the front of the
room or whatever they're studying
absolutely i can't stress enough how
important annual eye exams are honestly
for the whole family so if you want your
child to have their eyeglasses ready for
the start of the school year ideally you
should be on your doctor's schedule
about a month ahead of time because
glasses do take a little bit of time to
fabricate but if school's already in
session it's a great time of year to get
the whole family on the same schedule so
even if people in the family feel like
they're seeing well a comprehensive eye
exam can uncover lots of systemic
conditions like high blood pressure
diabetes cholesterol and even cancer and
as far as learning in the classroom
eighty percent of that is visual and so
a child needs to make sure that we are
seeing them and they're using their eyes
effectively efficiently in the classroom
and an eye care provider is perfect to
do that and should a child need glasses
there are some stylish ones out there
these days absolutely so what we want to
look for in a child's pair of eyeglasses
the first thing of course as a parent is
durability but we don't have to
sacrifice any style so i brought some
here today from my office to show you so
for some of our smaller patients we love
these frames by dilly dally they're
essentially indestructible and they come
in lots of fun colors that is good
that's important to have that durability
absolutely and so for some of our bigger
kids we like the spring hinges and
there's so many fun styles colors and
shapes this frame right here by lacoste
actually glows in the dark oh that's
cool and the kids love that absolutely
most kids in my practice are thrilled to
find out that they actually need glasses
they're excited to pick them out eye
care is so important for kids especially
these days because kids are spending so
much time online eye strain is a factor
absolutely i see signs of digital eye
strain in my patients all day long in
the practice what that can look like
varies from patient to patient the
symptoms can be a sore neck a headache
blurred vision tired eyes or even red or
irritated eyes and so some of the ways
that we can combat that in eye care we
call it the 20 20 20 rule so for every
20 minutes that you spend on a screen
you want to take 20 seconds and look at
something in the distance at least 20
feet away that will keep your eyes from
fatiguing and that's true for kids and
adults as well right absolutely
absolutely yeah because i mean we all
spend what feels like an inordinate
amount of time looking at computer
screens absolutely there are also
prescription lenses that your doctor may
determine that also can help with those
symptoms all right dr burke thanks so
much for being with us today thank you
so much for stopping
mercedes